Game show contestants have to overcome a lot
in order to emerge from the experience unscathed.
There's money at stake, pressure to win, and
just the general stress of being on television
for what's probably the first and only time
in their lives. It's not surprising, in other
words, when the stress makes them screw up
big time. Thankfully, the internet grants
these moments immortality, and we found some
of the best ones.
The worst Wheel of Fortune contestant ever
Indiana University honors student Julian Batts,
also known as the worst Wheel of Fortune contestant
ever, put in an epically awful performance
on the show that found him offering not one,
not two, but three forehead-slapping answers.
First, he flubbed the pronunciation of "Achilles."
"Mythological hero Achilles"
(buzzer)
Fair enough—let's just assume he never studied
Greek mythology and he isn't a Brad Pitt fan.
Next, he blew an incredibly easy chance to win a car.
"C!"
(buzzer)
"Can I solve?"
"Ya"
"The World's Fastest Man"
"Ya that's it"
But his guess on this puzzle...
...was this:
"On the spot dicespin"
(buzzer)
This guy thinks "dice spin" is one word—and
he also thinks you spin dice.
Needless to say, it was not Indiana University's
finest moment in the spotlight.
Another Wheel of Misfortune
Okay, you've got three letters remaining in
this puzzle…
You're probably gonna solve, right? Well,
that wasn't contestant Casey's plan. Instead
she made an on the spot dicespin.
Every hardcore Wheel-watcher knows she's playing
with fire, but she lucks out.
After guessing the 'G' in "nightclub," she
gets to pick up the $10,000. But then when
most sane people would have solved the puzzle—which
only had two letters left, Casey goes and
does this:
"Waddaya wanna do?"
"Spin!"
"Oh ok!"
Casey is playing the game show equivalent
of Russian Roulette at this point. The wheel
barely makes it one peg past Bankrupt. This
is complete insanity. All she has to do to
get that money is say "X" or "V"--you know,
the only letters left in the word "Exclusive."
"A letter?"
"A K"
(audience gasps)
No, Casey. Just no.
Romantic Geometry
Jeopardy! has always leaned towards the brainier
side of televised game shows. It takes itself
seriously—well, at least more seriously
than some of the competition.
"Fart in the bed"
That's why it was so surprising when contestant
Kara had this response to the clue:
"If Andy yearns for Brenda and Brenda cares
about Charlene who pines for Andy, the 3 of
them form one of these"
"Kara"
"What is a threesome?"
To be fair her answer isn't necessarily wrong.
But it isn't necessarily right, either. The
answer, of course, was "Love Triangle."
Host Alex Trebek, a seasoned pro, went in
for the kill.
"Kara has obviously had much more experience
than I"
Trebek, you old scoundrel.
Listening Helps
Family Feud contestant Holly just wanted to
win the faceoff to give her family the chance
to pass or play. So she didn't even let host
Steve Harvey finish the question:
"Name something a woman does for her baby,
that she-"
"Yes"
"Changes its diaper"
Bad move, Holly.
(buzzer)
She probably should've let Steve finish reading
his card.
"Name something a woman does for her baby
that she also does for her hubby."
On the other hand, maybe she and her husband
have an understanding! Who are we to judge?
You do you, Holly.
Some couples are truly made for each other
The Newlywed Game hangs its entire premise
on the uncomfortable reality that couples
may not know each other as well as they think
they do. In Gloria and Joe's case, this couldn't
be further from the truth. When asked:
"How many decades will your husband say his mother has lived?"
Gloria visibly realizes the trouble her husband,
Joe, would have with this answer, and yet,
she confidently states:
"Ten decades"
The audience laughs and thinks this is ridiculous,
but then Joe comes back out and we see that
Gloria knows her husband better than he knows
himself:
"Oh I dunno what a decade is. 44th Birthday so she'd be, that's 4 years a decade. She'd be 10 decades. 10 decades."
Joe, hold onto Gloria and never let her go.
You will never find a woman who understands
and accepts you like she does.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which game show fails you think should've
made the list...